vous avez été pendant 20 ans une
féministe pure et dure et puis un jour
là vous rencontrez Friedrich et ce
Frédéric a complètement transformé chez
high c'est vrai
plus ou moins
ça va chier
bonsoir
la traductrice oui vous appelez comment
Muriel bonsoir Muriel bonsoir vous avez
quel âge 44 44 vous êtes comment blonde
brune forte poitrine brune à forte
poitrine
attendez Muriel commencez pas essayer
d'être cachotière avec moi est-ce que
vous êtes marié non ah il y a une
ouverture Muriel peut-être
quoi après l'émission Muriel je rentre
elle essaie de faire payer
vous rentrez toute seule je crois oui
alors en fait chier ça vient de Charlie
votre prénom c'est Charlie on vous
appelle cher et je trouve que c'est bien
alors vous êtes mondialement connu pour
avoir publié en 1976 le rapport hight
sur la sexualité féminine et dans le
rapport high le premier rapport hype sur
la sexualité féminine on découvre ça va
vous intéresser
on découvre que 30% seulement des femmes
connaissent l'orgasme
dans la branche des Bourbons
82% se masturbent
95% obtiennent une satisfaction complète
ainsi est-ce que je peux vous poser une
question je vous en prie est-ce que vous
avez connu sans femme moi sans femme non
je pense pas non
pourquoi vous avez connu sans femme gros
parce que si vous aviez connu sans fin
il y en a 30 qui sont envoyés en l'air
[Applaudissements]
quelle conclusion on fait step by step
quelle conclusion avez-vous tiré de
cette première étude c'est-à-dire que
finalement 30% des femmes seulement
connaissent l'orgasme
quels sont les conclusions que j'ai
tirées du fait que la plupart des femmes
ont des engage grâce à la stimulation du
clitoris et bien vous savez que pendant
25 ans j'essaye de trouver un mot pour
la stimulus la stimulation du clitoris
je dirais le 6 potes donc les femmes
peuvent demander aux hommes de stimuler
je crois que c'est plus c'est plus
agréable que des directives est-ce que
tu pourrais me stimuler le clitoris avec
ta main par exemple vous êtes chez vous
vous avez de la chance vous êtes sur le
lit vous bougez pas génial vous bougez
pas pendant le jingle mais vous pouvez
essayer de mettre en pratique tout ce
que Chirac nous a appris grâce à ces
différents rapports au-delà de ça vous
dites que finalement à partir du moment
où les femmes obtiennent du plaisir seul
ça les rend sûr d'elle donc elle se
sentent moins imparfaite elle se sentent
moins anormales et elles peuvent se dire
un jour je serai président de la
République
vous savez que la plupart des femmes ont
arrive à l'orgasme assez facilement donc
si on pouvait peut-être changer la
définition du sexe même
mais vous savez que c'est Foucault qui
parlaient de cela
et Michel Michel Foucault
c'est Michel
de changer la définition du sexe
et je crois que c'est vrai mais nous
trouvons dans une époque où les gens
choses les choses changent par exemple
qu'est-ce qui a donné du champagne à
Muriel Muriel attention tu vas pas
rentrer toute seule bien alors donc le
premier bouquin de Shira le rapport Hyde
sur la sexualité féminine c'est vendu
vous êtes accroché là 20 millions
d'exemplaires traduit en 13 langues j'ai
gagné des millions de dollars je vais
vous dire un truc vous ressemblez un peu
à mon Seigneur avec vos yeux et tout là
vous descendez pas des rois de France
vous Gad Elmaleh c'est vrai que
quelque part oui au Maroc
à l'arrache vous viviez à l'arrache
aussi
à l'arrache bien sûr les oreilles
[Applaudissements]
bien ces trucs de ouf là dans l'anglais
Muriel quand il parle en arabe
en 1980 je continue votre vie chien vous
publiez le rapport hide sur la sexualité
des hommes et là vous dites encore c'est
des chiffres théorie extraordinaire vous
dites que les hommes américains
connaissent l'orgasme le plus puissant
en se masturbant
sexuelles une vie sexuelle seule et une
vie sexuelle avec leur partenaire et
voilà c'est comme ça que ça se passe
pour et ils aiment avoir faire l'amour
seul en fait ils peuvent même pouvoir
faire avoir des fantasmes allez
lentement sans avoir de pression sur
leur performances je crois que c'est
normal
[Rires]
en 87 troisième bouquin troisième
best-seller de chez high le rapport Hyde
sur les femmes et l'amour et alors là
98% des femmes sont mécontente de la
relation qu'elles ont avec leur conjoint
Caroline
75% des femmes américaines ont des
aventures extra-conjugales
après avoir été marié deux ans
70% des femmes mariées c'est d'avoir des
relations avec des autres hommes
c'est-à-dire que quand ce livre paraît
sa phase scandale on critique chez right
on critique sa méthode on dit que
finalement sa méthode ça consiste à
envoyer 100000 questionnaires par la
poste attendent la réponse et de livres
est écrit donc on la critique parce que
c'est des chiffres en pleine époque
reganienne ce sont des chiffres qui
choquent les puritains américains
évidemment
on dit aussi que les gens heureux ne
répondent pas à ce genre de
questionnaire peut-être les malheureux
qui répondent et même votre concierge
qui vous a balancé la concierge de shirt
a dit qu'elle avait rempli le
questionnaire avec ses copines en
écrivant n'importe quoi donc vous êtes
critiqué évidemment parce que
effectivement vous dites des choses
dérangeantes
exactement et surtout en ce qui concerne
les statistiques concernant les
aventures des femmes mariées pourtant
les âmes ont des aventures bien sûr et
dans mon livre précédent ça n'avait
choqué personne mais là dans ce nouveau
livre les statistiques choqués et il y a
eu une chasse aux sorcières en fait de
Salem un peu son histoire là vous
quittez les USA et donc à cette époque
là vous vous vivez en Europe vous êtes
en Europe
Muriel
[Rires]
et aujourd'hui
entre Londres Paris et Cologne et alors
Cologne peut-être parce que finalement
ce qu'il faut dire aussi il faut être
honnête vous avez été pendant 20 ans une
féministe pure et dure et puis un jour
là vous rencontrez Friedrich et ce
Frédéric a complètement transformé sur
c'est vrai
plus ou moins mais il est arrivé
féministe
purement
français
à ce moment-là quand elle a rencontré
Friedrich ma sexualité était inhibée et
vous l'avez écrit dans votre
autobiographique qui s'appelle le
rapport high sur high celui-là et vous
dites d'ailleurs que les féministes sont
les meilleurs amoureux alors
expliquez-moi ça c'est très important
parce que je connais bien Isabelle
Alonso avec Laurent Ruquier qui est
féministe et vous dites que les
féministes sont les meilleurs amoureux
pourquoi
et les famenistes sont les meilleurs
amoureuses parce que nous avons pas de
crainte
on atteint l'orgasme et on n'a pas
besoin de faire semblant d'atteindre
l'orgasme non plus le nouveau livre de
chien s'appelle sexe and business Muriel
sexe et business
et donc c'est publié aux échos alors ça
c'est incroyable journal Les Échos il
publie ce livre sexy business je sais
pas ce qui se passe aux échos alors
c'est un livre sur le comportement
sexuel des hommes et des femmes au
travail oui je pense que c'est une
nouveauté
en fait c'est une nouvelle situation car
dans le passé on pensait toujours que on
allait grandir
est-ce qu'on peut donner
[Applaudissements]
en français
comme une page blanche vous savez c'est
un nouvel ordre social que l'on pourrait
créer alors vous dites dans ce bouquin
alors attention ça c'est à faire flipper
dans les chaumières ça vous dites que
62% des femmes
Laurent
à la maison
non 62% des femmes ont des liaisons au
bureau
et alors ce qui est terrible c'est que
73% trouve ça négatif
vous savez c'est pas surprenant en fait
car après tout la plupart des relations
ne sont pas satisfaisantes aux femmes
donc c'est semblable au bureau mais
elles veulent continuer les expériences
71% des hommes ont des rapports sexuels
au bureau
et sur 71%, 61 qui trouve ça bien
marrant c'est gênant c'est un point un
peu plus tôt là ouais combien de femmes
au bureau 62% des femmes ont des
liaisons
71% des hommes
61 il y en a 9 qu'est-ce qu'ils font
alors après Shira est à poser d'autres
questions non mais c'est très
intéressant parce que la raison c'est un
nouveau lieu de d'expérimentation
sexuelle le bureau aujourd'hui
une question simplement
le harcèlement sexuel c'est vrai que
c'est insupportable quand un mec vient
une fille si tu veux de l'avancement ou
si tu veux un travail
laisse-moi te sauter bon ça c'est
pitoyable
ce n'est pas le sexe car on peut tomber
amoureux au bureau on peut être attiré
sexuellement par quelqu'un au bureau ce
n'est pas du de l'harcèlement sexuel on
a le droit d'aimer quelqu'un au travail
ça ne veut pas dire la même chose en
fait le harcèlement sexuel c'est
pitoyable courtisé les femmes
en France on est habitué c'est
culturelles pour nous et derrière les
Françaises quand elles vont aux
États-Unis elle se plaignent en revenant
c'est pas vous qui me le contraire elle
se plaignant surtout elle se plaignent
en revenant de pas avoir été courtisé
dans le livre je n'ai pas donné son nom
mais il a dit les femmes en France
seraient insultés si elle ne subissait
pas un harcèlement sexuel
mais les femmes elles aiment bien qu'on
les regarde et les Françaises quand
elles vont vivre aux États-Unis ou les
Italiens elles sont désespérées il y a
plus de mecs qui les regardent moi je
trouve que les manières en France sont
très agréables et du moment qu'on ne
prend pas les choses trop sérieusement
je trouve que c'est très bien bien de
pouvoir dire à quelqu'un vous êtes belle
aujourd'hui vous êtes belle je vous aime
beaucoup ça ne veut pas dire qu'on doit
coucher avec quoi aux États-Unis c'est
pas l'envie qui qui manque mais
simplement ils ont tellement peur des
procès
les sociétés ont peur d'être traînés en
justice alors pour éviter cela ils ont
des règles des règles d'ailleurs qui ne
fonctionne pas
vous arrivez quelque chose de terrible
maintenant est-ce que vous êtes prêts
oui
qu'est-ce que c'est après
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce qui va se
passer
Muriel ne t'en fais pas d'accord
c'est Line Renaud qui chante
c'est incroyable c'est une chanson
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour ou est-ce que vous avez
besoin de faire l'amour pour aimer
le premier vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour
pour aimer cher on se concentre adultère
Friedrich vous trompe imaginons
vous préférez ne pas savoir où vous êtes
partisan de tout vous dire
mais que j'ai bien sûr le droit de le
tuer
oh là là
est-ce que vous préférez un mec qui
baise très bien mais qui est infidèle
ou un mec qui baise mal mais qui est
fidèle les gars
c'est vraiment un esprit
avoir une femme pourrait s'amuser avec
un homme de toute façon donc bien sûr si
c'est pour s'amuser autant avoir l'homme
qui n'est pas fidèle dans ce cas-là je
n'aurais pas besoin d'être fidèle
moi-même
quel est pour vous le lieu idéal pour
une étreinte
le lieu idéal pour le sexe dans une
voiture
jamais essayé est-ce que vous avez un
fantasme que vous n'avez pas encore
réalisé
tout à fait
plein de trucs
mais les fantasmes ça va ça vient ça
change tout le temps il faut vite les
réaliser sinon après ça change de forme
donc
maintenant cette question m'a été envoyé
par Georges avec un J est-ce que vous
préférez
l'amour 5 fois par jour toute votre vie
avec le même homme ou une fois par mois
toute votre vie avec un homme différent
je crois que 5 fois par jour
mais bien alors un autre email une
question email d'Arnaud
siffrediche rate un rendez-vous
important l'après-midi et qui vient
faire l'amour avec vous
vous lui dites tu es fou ou tu me rends
folle
je dirais oui
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu